padam padam padam padam
mon père n'est pas mon pas la
mubadala
c'est ça enfin les lyonnais devient fou
je joue je viens de tout ranger mes
écoutes j'agis exactement comme tu le
fais puisque tu jettes tout est fourni
dans ma demain je ne vois pas pourquoi
je ne jetterai pas dans la tienne pas
quoi ta demeure enfin c'est maman la
fourbe y voyons c'est quand même pas de
ma faute si si toi abouti de dents
creuses ans le plus long qu'à y ait du
monde au casino depuis le temps tu
pourrais on a considéré cette malle
comme une chambre dame là qu'elle ne
soit pas très grande peut-être mais un
moment je n'ai plus un seul endroit pour
ranger mes fourbi enfin laisse léon et
son singe changera pas le rapport aux
autres jaunes de toute façon mais pas du
tout aujourd'hui il faut que ma maison
soit propre j'attends la visite de julie
mais c'est simple tu n'as qu'à l'est lui
pour elle et commerçants après tout
c'est un métier facile il suffit
d'acheter des objets et de les revendre
rien de plus sain tu crois ça léonard
et bien permets moi de te dire que tu te
trouves pas des excuses tout ce désordre
julie mais vraiment je ne pensais pas si
tôt mais casimir ça ne fait rien je suis
venu un peu plus tôt parce que
aujourd'hui mise affaire n'allait pas
très fort
les affaires par bones on aura tout
entendu dans ses dires mais c'est parce
que tu ne connais rien au camp vers
julie rabot parce que toi tu t'y connais
parfaitement je suis un as du commerce
je connais toutes les méthodes moyen de
comprendre tout ce que je veux et
éliminer ainsi la concurrence
est bien plus que tu es si fort pourquoi
n'es-tu pas je vais faire mais je vais
commencer aujourd'hui même je vais
incendiés et un grand jardin et dit ce
soir j'aurais fait forte et bien
doucement enfin si tu deviens champion
de la vente que forage lee le commerce
c'est comme le sport il faut que le
meilleur gagne aurez-vous note encore
mais je ne veux pas que mon ami soit
ruiné mais ne t'inquiète pas casimir
attendu d'abord de voir les méthodes
extraordinaire du sieur les audaces quoi
attendons
à léona oui je vais travailler tu m'as
travailler oui j'ai décidé de ne plus
vivre comme un vagabond et de gagner ma
vie et qu'elle travaille quand tu fais
le tour
toujours aussi drôle
non mais le clown pour devrait pas le
clown dans la vie le clown sur la piste
mais ça prend on ne devient pas un clown
comme ça bah justement je compte sur toi
pour m'apprendre je sais je ne connais
pas tout toutefois je veux bien essayer
de tb tu te déguise en auguste donc ils
font que je fasse le clown blanc
exactement moi j'ai plus le physique de
l'auguste que du clown blanc du col
prend pendant que tu te prépares j'avais
commencé mon humeur ou taqralik d'accord
[Musique]
bonjour les petits enfants je vais faire
un bon tour à qui vous savez
[Musique]
et
salut thomas salis leona comment ça va
quand bas sabat may léonard aucoin saint
trop bas parce que léonard parce qu'un
coin tomba parce que leona j'ai acheté
un chapeau qui est trop grand pour moi
que ça me tienne je vais te l'échanger
contre le mien le mien est un peu trop
petit justement il marche bien va donc
chercher un miroir qu'on puisse regarder
d'accord
[Musique]
j'ai pas tomber miroir ça permet un
tiens vaut un ancien pro
[Musique]
et ben
tu ferais mieux d'être marchand de
parapluie
[Musique]
je n'y arriverai jamais je me demande à
quoi peut bien servir cet objet
pas facile
alors quasiment tué deux nouveaux
commerçants de l'île aux enfants oui oui
mais évidemment il m'a laissé le plus
difficile à faire que veux tu dire lyon
n'a pas demandé de classer d'un côté
tous les ustensiles de cuisine et de
l'eau à tous ceux qui servaient pour le
bricolage a décoré tu es un peu perdu
veux tu que j'appelle les amphores
évidemment là c'est qu'on appelle les
enfants des sceaux et
les enfants venez vite venez vite casini
a besoin de vous vous allez me il était
un petit peu perdues une forme regardez
tous ces objets les enfants il ya dedans
des ustensiles de cuisine et des outils
pour le bricolage lors kazimiyah
voudrait qu'on sépare les deux voilà
c'est ça voulait bien l'aider oui oui et
vous si chez vous vous cherchez avec
d'un côté les ustensiles de cuisine de
l'autre les outils pour le bricolage ça
qu'est ce que c'est les enfants
une passe par nick moir c pour la
cuisine pour la cuisine alors j'en ai
dressé
voyons ceci est ce que c'est c'est une
pincée une pince multiples ça sert
pourquoi
tu as raison ça sert à serrer les écrous
très fort c'est pas un casque noir ici
bon fait pas cas ce magazine gay ceux-ci
bricolage cuisine
bricolage
[Musique]
un rouleau à pâtisserie c'est pour
étendre la pâte alors ça sert à quoi bah
la cuisine évidemment cuisine sauf
qu'est ce que c'est que ça
cuisine bricolage cuisine tu savais
quand même ça qu'est ce que c'est
une salière disent elles dans une
salière cuisine bricolage cuisine
évidemment je pense ceci
chercher chez vous
qu'est ce que c'est tu sais toi c'est un
ciseau à bois avrillé c'est tranchant là
ça sert à travailler le bois alors c'est
pour le bricolage la cuisine à part
évidemment
le plumeau ça compte dans les objets
casimir c'est un film c'est un film
autour du chalet pour essuyer met ses
pas dans les objets non non je ne
pourrais pas ceci en bas
c'est un m
c'est pour le bricolage ou à raison
exemple c'est un être client qui sert à
prendre toutes les mesures d'accord ceci
c'est un gros plus tôt ça sert à mettre
un maître de l'eau matériel on s'en sert
la cuisine
à la cuise et - surtout -
ceci
oui très bien
bricolage
découvert
cuisine
ici on mange avec ses doigts c'est une
louche ça sert à quoi la louche ça sert
à quoi
très bien alors servir la soupe ou sans
ses retours l'appui très bien alexandre
et enfin le dernier objet
tu as raison c'est une râpe pas
uniquement à gruyères ayant frappé du
griot mais on peut rappeler aussi des
carottes oui les bananes pour le groupe
bouygues a évidemment bien sûr y pense
toujours gloubiboulga alors cuisine
bricolage
cuisine évidemment bras casimir je crois
que tu peux remercier les enfants merci
à tous grâce à vous ça a été très vite
merci mes amis
les outils sont à droite puis les
ustensiles de cuisine la salle aragon
est joué et voilà les membres et julie
oui moi à quel prix van tu t'es bon bon
et bien 10 centimes
le secret du commerce c'est de vendre
moins cher que son voisin comme ça on
vend beaucoup plus et on gagne grains
d'argent
jeune yvan un caramel ou chocolat pour
10 centimes je vais donc en vendre deux
pour dix centimes
apprend chez les enfants allaient les
enfants vite vite approcher de caramels
mous pour 10 centimes un caramel 2
caramel pour 10 centimes approchez
approchez il y en aura pour tout le
monde repoussés parce qu'il sait pas
allez allez les enfants on met son arme
après la très bien julie que tu me
livrer tout de suite tout est bon s'il
te plaît à 10 centimes oui bien sûr
l'a63
très bien marco les mois sur canon
thurman entendons je ne les paierait
plus tard
approcher les enfants approchez
approchez venez manger n'est caramel des
bonbons 2 pour 10 centimes à prochain
projet
françois sémah
seigneur excuse moi je disais quelque
chose de passionnant mais c'est l'heure
de quoi en gardant la fermeture des
boutiques il faut vite aller voir si si
léonard a vendu plus qu'il rêvait de la
sienne la vie est si tu veux casimir
j'ai d'ailleurs l'impression que ça très
très bien marché pour lui chaque fois
que je regardais en direction de son
kiosque y avait plein de clients autour
et bien allons-y alors d'accord alosi
613 en journée alors léonard ont fait
ses comptes ou bonjour france - bonjour
bonjour casimir vous pouvez constater le
résultat de ma méthode regardez 6 113
francs c'est une belle recette n'est ce
pas pour une journée c'est certainement
la plus jolie recette jamais réalisé
dans l'île aux enfants mais minés alors
julie d'un rien vendu et que veux tu les
méthodes sont tellement efficace que la
malheureuse ne pouvait pas lui qui met
la pauvre c'est vrai à chaque fois que
je regardais en direction de son casque
hi rez aucun client au tour mais je vais
aller acheter quelque chose non oui
c'est gentil j'y vais avec toi
julie ne sera pas triste je viens
d'acheter une limonade mais je ne suis
pas triste du tout et je n'ai pas des
limonades alors une dragées au poivre
plus une seule
petits jouets alors plus mais que s'est
il passé mais vous n'avez pas remarqué
mon casse
c'est vrai il est bizarre alors le
kiosque de julie est complètement vide
explique nous tuer tous vendez tout
vendu hier qui a les honneurs
ça alors moi vraiment je ne comprends
plus rien qui se passait bien ça
pourtant les avares a choisi de vendre
les objets deux fois moins cher que chez
moi alors comme il a eu beaucoup de
clients il m'a acheté ma boutique et
voilà la facture mr léana
c'est fini
quoi quoi
8226 francs mais mais mais c'est
impossible je je je n'ai pas assez
d'argent
léonard c'est un petit peu de ta faute
tu sais mais réfléchie du https objets
deux fois plus cher que de les a
revendues ensuite c'est ainsi que toute
la journée tu as perdu de l'argent
[Musique]
n'était pas si bonne que ça tient mon à
marseille pour le reste et bien à tien
je te paierai en honneur de ménage
casimir peut le dire que j'ai une
méthode
[Musique]